retrouve manger sesvotés avec le
concours général
agricole retrouver manger
svés avec Mutualia la mutuelle des
[Musique]
territoires bonjour à tous je suis
devant le château de ponne belle cité de
la somme je voulais pas que vous pensiez
il est passé par la somme ilite pon
aujourd'hui on va visiter ce beau
département en compagnie du sénateur
Rémy Cardon benjamin du Sénat et faisant
partie du groupe socialiste écologiste
et républicain il va nous emmener à la
visite de la somme qui est un une terre
vraiment
agrre
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur le sénateur bonjour
vous allez bien oui formidable vous
étiez en train de contempler c'est beau
volatile c'est pas le mipè sont signes
de Camon alors ça me fait drôle à mon
avis je suis pas le seul vous appelz
monsieur le sénateur et d'avoir un
sénateur qui l'â d'être mon fils grosso
modo mais ils sont nombreux au Sénat à
avoir ce rapport avec vous j'ai eu
effectivement des des maladresses mais
il y a aussi de la bienveillance aussi
auprès de mes collègues ça se passe
plutôt bien paternalisme ouais parfois
il Kos mais après eux ils ont passé
quelques années pour arriver sénateur et
puis moi je suis sur les starting bloc
trèsôt donc à la fois curieux par le le
spécimen remémy Cardon je pense en tout
cas et après plutôt de la bienveillance
pour aller pour travailler ensemble vous
avez quel âge aujourd'hui 29 29 et vous
êtes entré au au Sénat à 26 26 26 donc
plus jeune sénateur de la 5e République
d'après
[Musique]
Wikipédia j'imagine il a fallu faire vos
pruves très vite hein exactement 2 mois
après on arrivé euh j'ai dû convaincre
mes collègues socialiste dans mon groupe
les 64 sénateurs que il fallait une
proposition loi sur l'extension du RSA
pour les moins de 25 ans donc des droits
nouveaux des 18 ans au vu de la
précarité étudiante qu'on a pu vivre et
conv encore aujourd'hui euh j'ai voulu
lancer ce débat dans une assemblée
plutôt conservateur je peux vous dire
que ça a eu de l'écho et derrière
j'étais assez satisfait tout de même
même si le résultat a été négatif à la
fin mais ce qui est intéressant c'est
que ça a amené le débat et il y a eu des
sondages autour de ça et les Français
étaient plus plutôt favorables à
l'époque et donc ça veut dire que j'ai
fait une partie du chemin et en plus
vous avez dit moi le rythme sénatorial
c'est pas le mien on m'a dit alors le
train de sénateur c'est quoi mais non
moi je dis c'est le TGB oui maintenant
grâce à moi c'estend le TGB très bien
est-ce que vous avez eu un un mentor
politique j'ai pas eu de mentor plutôt
des inspirations ouais par exemple
j'étais bouleversé ou un moment où je
j'étais avec mon père aux ruees au resto
universitaire et mon père m'a pointé du
Do m'a dit regarde tu vois ces deux
étudiants justement ils ont un plateau
pour deux et là je me suis dit j'étais
assez jeune et je dis ah ouais comment
ça se fait j'ai fais un peu le naïf et
il m'a dit bah ils vont devoir le
partager et c'est aussi là-dessus où
j'ai voulu me dire que je devais
m'engager en politique c'est un peu le
déclic et puis j'ajoute à ça le la
dignité dans les dans les logements
insallubles que j'ai pu voir aussi de
mes propres yeux j'ai été assez proche
des valeurs de la Fondation abépierre
des combats qu'il a pu mener à une
certaine époque pour moi pour moi dans
la République française pour que tout le
monde y trouve son compte et et qu'on
ait confiance en cette république il
faut que chaque personne puisse se loger
et se nourrir et après toutes les autres
étapes derrière peuvent découler si je
comprends bien la la valeur essentielle
de votre engagement chez les socialistes
c'est le partage le partage le partage
de la valeur chacun peut partager en
fonction de ses revenus c'est la
question sociale et la question
écologique donc je me suis bien trouvé
au Parti socialiste alors dans cette
ville l'eau est partout puisquelle est
traversée par la Somme avec de nombreux
bras les ortillonnages ce sont ces îlos
de verdure vous m'emmenez les voir allez
on peut y aller à l'heure du déjeuner
nous serons à la table du marécher un
restaurant interentreprise qui cuisine
les légumes locaux et pour le dessert
nous irons goûter les yaourts fermers de
Jerry compère puis direction argoule
dans la baie de Somme pour ouvrir
quelques pâtées é thérines de la famille
vos avant de rendre visite alor une
belle bergère qui garde ses moutons des
agneaux de prê salé mais tout de suite
direction les ortillonnages d'Amien au
bord de la somme ces jardins aquatique
ce sont les hortillonnages la racine
horticulture
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hortillonnage quelqu'un
ah bonjour ah bonjour bonjour fré
bienvenue à l'Î au FRU bonjour c'est
vous le reinon de l'île au frruit ah on
essayie de survivre sur les les
ortillonnages et sur les marais alors
qu'est-ce que vous avez comme parcelle
on est sur ce qu'on appelle de la micro
agriculture on est sur un hectare au
total de surface productive entre
guillemets et puis surtout rotation
permanente quasiment des des parcelles
de façon à ce que on a systématiquement
quelque chose de cultiv toute l'année et
donc dans les ser comme à l'extérieur on
a la chance d'être sur une terre très
fertile on est sur le lit de la somme
sur les aluvions qui ont été apportés
pendant des dizaines de milliers
d'années les ortienage constitue un
écosystème très productif depuis très
longtemps autour d'Amien combien est-ce
qu'il reste de de maréé comme ça dans
les or oua donc on était il y a un
siècle plus de 1000 il y avait sur les
250 hactares 300 maximum des
sortillonnages 1000 marécher on est
aujourd'hui moins d'une quinzaine avec
une surface cultivée qui dépasse passe
pas les les 15 20 hectares donc du coup
oui le modèle est interrogé face à
l'agriculture intensive face à
l'agriculture de plein champ alors qu'on
a la chance d'être au milieu de la
population les ortillonnages à Amien ça
invite dans la ville on est au pied de
la cathédrale donc c'est le circuit
court par excellence les ortil à nage
Damien c'est une image d'épinale ou quoi
c'est les erreurs du passé c'estàdire
que il y a eu des privatisation de
parcell pour faire parfois des cabanes
Airbnb parfois des juste un jardin perso
à titre perso en tout cas quand vous
devez lancer une petite exploitation
agricole et que le coût du foncier
représente 10 fois le coût d'une d'une
exploitation à 10 15 20 km on n'est pas
effectivement sur le même pied d'égalité
et on se tire une balle dans le pied
[Musique]
elle a une couleur incroyable cette
terre c'est ça c'est la terre d'ici ou
oua vous avez pas mis dessus de l'UR
brun il y a des endroits encore plus
tourbeux dans les ortillonnages HE la
tourbe c'était ce qui permettait de se
chauffer il y a quelques dizaines
d'années bien sûr bien sûr on est quand
même obligé d'arroser malgré la présence
de de l'eau tout autour de nous frééric
de quoi avez-vous besoin de plus de
mains de plus d'ingéerie de terr
supplémentaires on a besoin
effectivement que les circuits courts
aujourd'hui puissent lutter à armes
égales avec la la grande distribution on
a des logiques agro-industrielles
auxqueles on a du mal à à faire face en
organisant au plus près du terrain la
logistique le marketing autour des
circuits courts des choses que les
agriculteurs savent pas faire forcément
on nous enlèverait une bne Lespine du
pied et on pourrait effectivement
discuter lutter pas armes égales mais en
tout cas en tout cas paraître aux yeux
des consommateurs non pas comme les
petits artisans du coin mais avoir des
capacités d'intervention et de
distribution au moins égal et la
question du du foncier très clairement
aujourd'hui si on n'est pas aidé de ce
point de vue-là il y aura pas d'autres
nouvelles installations il y aura en
tout cas des difficultés pourquoi ça
passe pas parce que il y a une peut-être
une volonté de de péréniser plutôt un un
une agriculture dite agroalimentaire les
en particulier gros on sent il y a un
lobbying très fort aussi au Sénat en la
matière donc pourquoi aujourd'hui les
petites parcelles et en particulier
l'ilofruit en est l'exemple pourquoi ils
sont pas subventionnés à leur juste
valeur parce que ils apportent vraiment
un contenu de de qualité en plus à
proximité de ville comme à mien merci
beaucoup Fred bravo pour ce que vous
faites à bientôt
etage alors monsieur le sénateur c'est
l'heure du déjeuner vous m'emmenz où là
à la table du mariché c'est un
restaurant interentreprise qui lit
circuit court puisil alimente unble
d'pad de restauration scolaire et puis
surtout il travaill sur la stion
professionnelle puisque il y a des
personnes en sitation de handicap qui
travaillent ici ah bah écoutez au moins
il ment pas sur leur nom la table du
marécher on est accueilli par les
maréchés d'ce qu'il viennent ces beaux
légumes là de Jin cour donc du maréage
sans phyo ah pas bio mais sans phyo
voilà tout à fait bon ben génial si
c'est ça qu'on sert à table
[Musique]
bonjour Laurent bonjour vcent alors vu
votre chemise et votre gabarit je Demre
pas si c'est le patinage artistique qui
vous intéresse ah non non du tout le
rugby alors on arrive en pleine heure du
déjeuner comment est-ce que ça
fonctionne sur l'organisation du
personnel ici on a une plateforme de
formation on estsom établissement public
de santé médicosociale ACC des personnes
en situation handicap pour les former au
métier de la restauration parce que
notre priorité c'est l'inclusion bien
sûr bien sûr la formation et l'inclusion
mais chaque jeune chez nous est épanoui
et notre plus belle réussite c'est voir
les usagers sortir d'ici et trouver du
boulot bon on voit qu'il y a un accent
qui est mis sur la qualité j'ai vu par
exemple ce buffet de dessert mil feuill
fondant chocolat tarte àtin pour quel
pour quel ticket moyen ici 5 à 6 € pour
un menu complet oui un menu complet
ouais ouais donc je sais pas comment
vous tenez vos coups alors ben c'est
très dur c'est très compliqué mais on a
on a la chance de pouvoir travailler
avec des producteurs locaux hier j'étais
sur fontaine sur Somme parce que on a
réservé quatre bœufs là pour mois
d'octobre pour la bête à l'équilibre
chez Monsieur Parsy on a la chance de
pouvoir toucher Bourignon du steak du
rose beef ou de la saucisse campagnard à
13,50 € le kilo
ouais faut le rappeler quand même la
Somme 80 % sont des terres agricoles et
donc il faut connecter nos circuits
court en fonction des des des
arrondissements et des secteurs qu'on
peut avoir la somme on a des vraies
spécialités vous venez d'où vous votre
parcours c'est quoi votre métier à la
base cuisinier moi je suis cuis voilà
non parce que j'allais me dire c'est pas
un administratif si vous êtes aussi
obsessionnel de la qualité du produit de
la cuisine qui est servie c'est que
c'est votre votre cœurine BP cuisine
Suren au hôier et combien ça fait de de
repas servis par jour ici sur le site
700 alors je sais pas pour vous
monsieurateur mais moi je commence à
avoir un tout petit peu avec les odeurs
qui montent de la cuisine est-ce que je
peux me faire un petit plateau avec
grand plaisir ça vous intéresse et on y
va
alors ça sent bon ça c'est aubergine ah
croquette voilà que des aubergine vous
c'est normal vous avez la ligne et la
viande où lait avec des légumes
qu'est-ce que c'est ça ah c'est une
saucisse au Maroil au Mar ou Mar
l'honneur des ha France quand même on la
partage hein parce qu'elle est elle est
elle est énorme bon ben je suis pas venu
pour rien j'ai ma S6 et on avait dit
qu'on partageait
[Musique]
hein alors où est-ce qu'on est ici à
busu 230 habitants ah oui et donc on est
à la ferme compère que la coutume ici
c'est de boire du Lescu directement
quand on
[Musique]
arrive on se sert à la la tireuse
exa et puis voilà la la protéine le lait
il a un autre goût quand il est quand il
sort de la vache he ah voilà Jéry c'est
le propriétaire bonjour j attendez donc
je vous ai préparé un assortiment de de
ah vous faites aussi des yaourts ici
yaourt produit sur la ferme voilà génial
bah écoutez à quoi ils sont ceux-l
Véronique tu peux est dans la boutique
bonjour madame bonjour ah ben vous vous
avz les cuillères elle avait prévu elle
avait prévu pr alors sont des yaourts
fermiers oui mais on n pas le droit
d'écrire fermierers dessus pourquoi en
fait la législation nous l'interdit
parce que dans mon yaourt en fait je
rajoute du sucre qui est pas produit sur
notre exploitation des fruits qui ne
sont pas produits non plus sur notre
exploitation mais alors si je comprends
bien vos yaourts nature en revanche ils
ont le droit d'être inscrit il a
fermierers oui tout à
fait ils sont ils sont bon c'est yaourt
hein ben moi ce qui m'intéresserait
c'est qu'on aille voir vos vaches ouis
là elles sont en pâure elles sont en
pâure quasiment toute
l'année je vois qu'il y a une sorte de
mix de variété vous êtes pour la
diversité ouais tout à fait alors là ici
vous avez de la rain euh ensuite une
race très intéressante c'est la simental
par sa rusticité elle est bien adaptée
ici elle est bien adapté au type
d'élevage biologique voilà c'est-à-dire
sans
maïs parce que vous vous faites du lait
bio du lait bio à l'herbe grosso modo
dans la Somme ça a du mal à passer
parfois face aux grandes exploitations
de de pomme de terre de blé et cetera le
bio c'est un peu la partie conrue
malheureusement les parents pauvres de
de l'agriculture samarienne c'est un
vrai combat moi je je milite en tout cas
pour que on oriente notamment les
subventions de la pack vers le bio pour
accompagner faire transiter un maximum
d'agriculteurs vers le bio transition
trans en fait ce que vous nous dites
c'est qu'on veut pas être à la fois bio
et locavore pas dans notre système
aujourd'hui Jéry vous êtes agriculteur
toute l'eau qui tombe pas du ciel il
faut la compenser par de l'eau qui vient
du sous-sol comment comment ça marche
pour vous par exemple tout risque d'être
remis en cause au canal c'est Nord
Europe si parce que parce que enfin vous
connaissez l'ouvrage c'est Nord Europe
oui donc il y a 70 communes autour là on
est en plein dedang et donc il y a un
remodelage de l'ensemble du parcellaire
c'estàd ici je suis pas sûr que ça sera
encore chez moi euh ah bon voilà vous
risquez d'être exproprié on dit bah toi
au lieu d'avoir 10 parcelles de de 1
hactare tu as une parcelle de 10
hectares làb voilà vous savez un canal
de plus de 100 km on attend ça en 2030
euh c'est un enjeu majeur pour la somme
mais en même temps les compensations
environnementales sont attendues et
l'enjeu de l'eau autour de ce canal
aussi euh est-ce qu'on va être en
capacité de le remplir demain si il fait
plus de 2 degrés plus de 3°grés plus de
4°gr avec les barorations deau
aujourd'hui les estimations des services
de la société du canal c'est on tient
bon jusqu'à plus 1,5 demain la diversité
dans dans bussus si si j'ai un bloc de
50 heares d'un côté un bloc de 50 heares
ailleurs il y aura plus de pinture il y
aura plus plus de diversité et moi je
m'orienterai comme tout le monde avec
vers des pommes de terre et cetera VO
voilà oui l'Asie mange de la frite en
fait la pomme de terre produite en
Picardie
elle est travaillée par les industriels
belges et une grosse partie je crois que
c'est 3 millions de tonnes qui part dans
les marchés un petit camion hein quand
même j'ai pas de droit d'eau spécifique
attribué au pintur et pour avoir ce
droit d'eau je vais être obligé de
biaiser en en faisant des champs de
Patat pour les des pomes de voilà sous
le compte de la distribution d'eau on va
réussir à les tuer tous ces petits
agriculteurs on se retrouve dans une
situation où si la somme avec son
patrimoine agricole n'a pas voation à
chercher une transition vers le bio pour
qu'on soit un territoire d'avenir on va
louper le coche et on sera
malheureusement ceux qui vont servir les
frites en
Chine donc là on est à argoule dans bom
et on va visiter la conserverie
artisanale Saint-Christophe ah bah la
fameuse famille vanost exactement Éric
et Simon ouais Simon a repris
l'entreprise de son père et ils font en
fait des terines qui sont vraiment des
marqueurs forts de ce
[Musique]
France ça Simon c'est les autoclaps ça
oui les cocottes minutes du conserveur
ah oui c'est votre casserole à vous quoi
là ça a été cuit en fait hier et on va
le sortir pour passer à l'étitage
monsieur le sénateur on rappelle le
principe de l'apertisation hein de la
conserve ok c'est comporte à plus de 100
deg alors c'est plutôt 110 120 ouais 116
116° en fait c'est d'avoir 100 degr à
cœur pour vraiment être être stable éic
vient de transmettre l'entreprise à son
fils hein c'est ça oui et vous vous avez
démarré il y a une trentaine d'années
j'ai démarré en 90 d'accord on a
commencé à faire des conerves avec un
tout petit autoclave où on mettait 140
bocau maintenant on en met 500 dans un
autocl en c'est incroyable la
conserverie c'est un métier à part
comment est-ce qu'on fait la différence
justement entre l'industriel et
l'artisanal bah l'artisanal déjà c'est
une façon de faire c'est prendre du bon
produit faire quelque chose vraiment
avec son âme avec on aime notre métier
mon père m'a transmis ça et
artisanalement c'est aussi on fait 40 %
de notre production à la main quasiment
ah ouais c'est une manufacture donc ici
plus Industri man voilà exactement on
est agréé C eu et on est aussi
agroalimentaire c'est normal aussi qu'on
a des beau locaux on peut pas faire ça
dans la Vieille Étable avec l'étoile
d'arign
souris qui passent ce n'est pas possible
et puis l'avantage par rapport à une
boîte de conserve c'est que le bocal
c'est transparent donc il y a pas besoin
de long discours ce qui est à
l'intérieur on le voit voit on peut pas
tricher VO consommateur c'est important
goûter ou
pas on y va parce qu'on cause on cause
et puis on goûte pas
grandchose alors évidemment le gras
remonte un peu c'est un signe de qualité
oui parce que il y a pas de texturant
qui mélange le gras au reste c'est ça
ouais parce qu'on pourrait se dire oh là
là ça tient pas leur truc le gras
remonte non au contraire on va sortir ça
avec la gelée naturelle en dessous voilà
hein ça c'est le jus de cuisson la gelé
en
fait je va permet hein bien
sûr pas trop salé et ça c'est difficile
le dosage hein c'est bon hein ça pousse
à faire des planches àau avec de lari
voilà voilà vous vous êtes des obsédés
de votre B somomme donc vous prenez au
maximum les produits de la bomme faut
mettre en avant son territoire on va pas
aller chercher des agneaux des moutons
ou des bœufs de l' bout du monde
écologiquement c'est zéro mais c'est ce
que fer l'industrie par exemple il vous
ferit juste une terine de canard ouais
mais on est pas industriel on est
artisan c'est ça la
[Musique]
différence
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
bonjour Laur
bonjour Simon Bos il m'a dit faut aller
VO ou Simon bah oui j'habitaé à 4 km de
chez lui j'ai travaillé tous mes étés
là-bas m'a dit tu verras elle est au
milieu des pressalés une belle bergère
seule isolée dans ses moutons la se he
en fait c'est juste ça il y a pas
d'autres bergères ici dans ici non
beaucoup en montagne mais ici non la
somme j'ai encore un peu du mal avec la
parité hein et comment ça vous est venu
vous en fait je m'occupa de promouvoir
l'association des prés salés et de gérer
leur partie administra d'accord et en
fait je suis tombée amoureuse du métier
de la vie ici quoi mais vous avez été
confronté aux dures réalités du terrain
j'imagine he j'ai passé un an dans une
bergerie et par contre la baé j'ai mis 2
ans à vraiment bien la connaître à
connaître les D
que c'est une vaste pleine verte mais
non il y a des courants et en fonction
des marées il y a des zones plus hautes
plus basses parce que l'eau peut
remonter très haut ouais elle peut
arriver jusqu'à la route ave des forts
coefficients alors ils sont où les
moutons quand les quand la Mar est très
haute on a une pinture on appelle ça une
zone de repli et à forte marée on doit
les mettre dans des pintures juste de
l'autre côté de la digue permettez une
seconde jeis vérifier un truc c'est quoi
le
truc qu'est-ce que c'est
l'herve vouz goû
elle est bonne mais oui mais elle est
salée oui c'est ça c'est pas juste du
marketing quoi quand on dit prè salé les
prê sont réellement sal c'est vraiment
prè salé ouais avec des plantes alopit
résiste VO comment vous gérez la
situation avec justement la garde des
prix l'inflation est-ce que c'est
compliqué pour vous bah c'est un peu
compliqué parce que à la base on
arrivait à valoriser 35 et 45 % plus
cher qu'un agneau classique don c'est
une vraie valorisation aujourd'hui avec
l'inflation on n plus du tout à ça on
est à 20 % plus cher 15 à 20 % plus cher
qu'un agneau classique français donc ce
qui fait que moi par exemple l'année
dernière j'ai j'ai perdu 6000 € ah oui
ouais onarrive plus à marger quoi non
plus du tout mais effectivement va
falloir que je me trouve à un autre
projet parce que je dépends complètement
moi j'ai que des moutons j'ai pas de
terre et cetera donc si je ne me trouve
pas une autre quelque chose d'autre en
j'aimerais trouver quelque chose d'autre
qui me permettrait de faire ce métier là
par plaisir
malheureusement vous imaginez quoi là
j'aimerais bien faire de l'agritourisme
euh parce que j'ai ma petite cabane de
bergère que je loue en Airbnb du coup
hein je suis partie revivre chez mes
parents pour louer mon logement et qui
fonctionne très bien donc j'aimerais
mettre des tiny house C'est des
roulottes modernes et à la fois faire
comprendre aussi mon métier à ceux qui
logent chez moi quoi être éleveuse
aujourd'hui d'un mouton AOP fierté de la
Somme et de la France parce qu'il fait
partie de ce panier d'excellence ne
suffit pas à vous faire vivre ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que au fond on
l'achète pas assez cher nous les
consommateurs oui mais je pense qu'on se
rend plus du tout compte du prix de la
nourriture justement on a tellement
développé les loisirs et cetera que
maintenant tout est centré sur les
loisirs et plus sur la qualité
alimentaire c'est à cause de la
mondialisation ça a transformé l'état
d'esprit des consommateurs sur la
consommation le fait de remplacement C
avec des choses divers et variés du
monde entier alors qu'on aurait pu
peut-être tout simplement s'occuper des
produits àx ité et on pensait qu'après
le covid on allait sortir voilà à fond
les circuits courts tout le monde se
relance làdedans les artisans et cetera
et au final vous êtes plutôt sensible à
la possibilité d'un protectionnisme
alimentaire européen européen parce que
je pense qu'on sera plus fort si on a un
protectionist européen pour se battre
dans le monde entier oui mais vous
sentez bien quand même bien évidemment
si on peut valoriser les produits du
territoire c'est encore mieux merci
beaucoup en merci à vous je vous
souhaite que les prix montent parce que
vous le méritez votre agneau il est
formidable oui merci merci
[Musique]
beaucoup incroyable ce moulin ça doit
être un des sommets de la Somme ici
c'est le Moulin de cour ouais on est
dans cette commune et on va aller voir
l'Auberge du Moulin saintabanque le
restaurant où on a un chef charismatique
Sébastien Porquet
d'accord et je suppose qu' va nous faire
une spécialité du coin ah on va voir on
va voir on va voir moi je connaissais le
chef Sébastien Porquet mais je ne
connaissais pas la souschef c'est qui la
souschef je porqu j Porquet est toujours
dans le coin pour finer un coup de main
de toute façon vous avez promis une
ficelle picarde mais c'est une ficelle à
votre manière ouais on aime bien faire
les choses à notre manière ici on va la
faire un petit peu plus costaud il y a
essentiellement que les Ch
et en fait on fait juste une duxelle de
champignon sont juste Saché pour
remplacer le fameux jambon du sanglier
monsieur le sénateur va pouvoir trancher
vous êtes de droitier ou gaucher gauch
l'idée en fait c'est de faire des fines
lamell
PC bon après moi je pense qu' s je suis
pas aussi bon non plus
quoi notre tombé de champignon
l'objectif en fait dans cette ficelle
c'est le champignon regardez
bien rentrer ouais
TI le saucisson que pour la crêpe on
essaie de faire des carrés avec des
ronds si j'ai bien compris ou c'est ça à
chaque fois
c'est le défi du monde puis après j
c'est à toi là je l'avais dit ah oui
Joséphine il faut qu'elle nous montre
donc là en fait c'est elle qui va
disposer les petites plantes bon chef on
prend nos ficelles où est-ce qu'on peut
se mettre je vous laisse vous installer
dehors je vous apporte un verre de vin
voilà la cour de berinis produit
audessus d'Amien ah bon c'est un vin de
la Somme voilà premier rouge en fait
peut-être des haute France messieurs bon
appétit mer chef
ouais c'est pas mal hein je suis assez
surpris il se défend
bien je me posaer cette question au bout
de cette journée passée avec vous reméy
on a pratiquement eu que des produits
des préparations et même du vin tout
dans la Somme c'est un département
autosuffisant sur le plan agricole c'est
un département qui détient si on en CIT
les terres autour de nous 80 % de ces
terres sont agricoles donc à la fois il
y a un vrai réseau agricole puissant à
patrimoine je dirais patrimoine agricole
de la somme est remarquable on est
reconnu pour ça où est-ce qu'il y a des
points noirs dans la Somme qu'est-ce
qu'il faut améliorer en tout cas moi mon
rêve c'est que chacun ait les moyens de
se payer une ficelle picarde tout le
temps et je pense qu'il faut une
sécurité sociale alimentaire ça fa faire
partie de mes combats futur et la carte
Vitale comme F l' peti elle est vitale
et l'alimentation c'est vitale et je
pense que là-dessus ça fait partie des
combats de demain parce que c'est pas
normal qu'on voit des gens mourir de
faim merci beaucoup micardon à la somme
alors à la somme on se retrouve bientôt
sur manger ses beauté ou sur la
plateforme publicsena.fr à
[Musique]
bientôt c'était manger svuté avec
Mutualia la mutuelle des
[Musique]
territoires
c'était manger ses vter avec le concours
général
agricole